pour le douzième jour consécutif
plusieurs milliers de manifestants sont
descendus dans la rue pour réclamer la
libération d'aung san suu kyi
massivement organisée via les réseaux
sociaux
ces rassemblements se voit mis à mal par
des coupures internet régulière depuis
le début de la contestation des cortège
composé de nombreux jeunes qui subissent
de plein fouet
c'est pas d'internet contrairement à
leurs aînés quasiment coupés
numériquement du monde jusqu'en 2013 et
la fin du monopole d'état sur les
télécommunications la nouvelle
génération birmane a été bercée par les
réseaux sociaux une privation de liberté
qui ne sera pas acceptée par les jeunes
birmans selon le rapporteur spécial des
nations unies sur les droits de l'homme
en birmanie
ils ont entendu les histoires de leurs
parents et de leurs grands parents sur
les horreurs de la vie sous un régime
militaire brutale
ils ont l'expérience de ce que c'est que
d'avoir des libertés donc ils sont
attachés à la liberté au fait de ne
jamais avoir à vivre le cauchemar que
leurs parents et leurs grands parents
décrivent les militaires birmans sont
soupçonnés par les nations unies
d'organiser ces coupures pour permettre
l'identification d'opposants tout en
bloquant les possibilités de communiquer
entre manifestants la junte est
également suspecté de vouloir s'inspirer
de la grande muraille informatique mise
en place par la chine pour contrôler
l'environnement numérique nationale
pékin qui fournirait son expertise sur
le sujet au militaire actuellement au
pouvoir
des affirmations démenties par le vice
ministre birman de l'information il est
impossible de le faire avec l'aide de la
chine si nous voulons le faire nous
avons suffisamment d'experts pour le
faire changer de cap ligne à tenir face
à ces restrictions les jeunes birmans
tombe de trouver la parade
outre l'utilisation de cartes sim
étrangères la fréquentation des vpn les
réseaux privés virtuels sont plébiscités
ils permettent aux internautes de
masquer leur adresse ip et de se
connecter à l'extérieur du réseau
national
le site top 10 vpn basés en
grande-bretagne a par exemple fait état
d'une hausse de près de sept mille deux
cent pour cent de la demande en vpn
après l'interdiction de facebook en
birmanie le 4 février dernier les
méthodes qui sont loin d'être novatrice
elles ont déjà largement été utilisé
lors de précédentes manifestations
massives
a hong kong ou en thaïlande